- Right, so you, Emma and Rupert,
y'all got together for a sit down recently
for Harry Potter reunion recently.
- Yeah.
- So--
(audience cheering)
was that cool?
'Cause you were so young
- Yeah.
- and I think that's kind of cool
'cause y'all had so many
memories probably together
when you were that young.
- Yeah, no, it was awesome.
Like to, I didn't know how
I would feel going back
and it was actually incredibly lovely
to like see everyone again and
- Yeah.
- people that you've own only
had like childhood conversations with
that you actually then
get to talk to as adults,
yet, it did end up being
really, really special.
And there are some memories
that you only, like
I don't know you that only
come back to you when you are
kind of there together
- Yeah.
- all remembering stuff.
So yeah, it was, it was very, very,
yeah, it was really special.
- That's so cool.
I recently, literally, my kids asked
to go on separate dates,
but they both wanted to go to Universal
- Okay.
- and they both wanted
to see Harry Potter.
- Yeah.
And so we went to the
ride and I kept thinking
did, have you ever like snuck
in there to do the ride?
- I've not snuck in.
- Come on!
- I went to the opening
when it opened in Florida,
I went to the one there.
- It would be amazing if you snuck in
and then just took off
your hat on the ride
and looked to the left or
something or the right.
- Maybe it would be amazing,
but the people would just be
like, this ride is amazing.
It's like, really they
thought of everything.
- Does this happen?
- Does everyone get this?
But yeah, no, there's also,
they just opened a store,
there's like a massive Harry
Potter store in New York now
and I'm often like walking
to a friend house.
- What?
- Yeah, yeah.
- I'm a nerd.
- Oh, yeah, I'm keeping it in.
- You should totally go.
- But like, okay,
I am gonna go.
- Yeah.
- But fear not.
- I also like
walk past there and
I'll suddenly get there,
I'm like, oh no, I'm here.
I have to not be here very quickly,
I have to run before somebody sees me.
Yeah.
- That's awesome
or exciting for a lot of people.
Well, we're such fans.
The movie is amazing.
- Thank you so much.
- It's so good.
Congratulations.
(audience cheering)
I loved it.
Thank you for coming by.
- Always, thank you.
- Thank you for trying
our nasty.
- Thank you.
- Daniel Radcliffe, everybody.